today i'm speaking to 21 year old
nilikantha banu
who won the gold medal for india at the
2020
mine sports olympiad and he holds a few
world records
for being the world's fastest human
calculator
the numbers are seven seven nine seven
two eight seven three four
seven thousand four
i think we first got in contact with
each other after i made a video about
shakuntala devi from india and
she previously i think held this record
for you know fastest human calculator
and yeah i'm wondering have you beaten
her record
and if so what what was that record
shakuntala devi
was let's say one of the first
math magicians if i have to put it this
way who has established
math as a performance actor which is
that
going on the stages making people clap
maybe making people enjoy the art of
let's say solving questions in front of
them she held a lot of world records but
there's this one specific
world record which is called the fastest
human calculator record
where one gets to add a number to itself
as quickly as possible if it's
a two-digit number if i have to put it
this way u1 has to do the multiples of
it very quickly
and say the answers out so if i start
with 28 it goes 28 56 84 112 140 168 and
so on so on
so the record is to do as many times
in 15 seconds so these records were once
held by her
mr scott flansburg from the united
states and that's the record which i've
broken
a couple of years ago in racing past and
doing it for 42 times in 15 seconds
i've seen some videos of it done and
yeah i find it really impressive
and in fact when i first read the story
of shakuntala
and then heard your story as well my
initial thoughts
uh and maybe these are the thoughts of
many people it's like
wow that is such a special talent
and those people seem so different to me
because i you know i feel like i could
never do that
and and i think many people maybe feel
the same i wonder if you could answer
you know
is there something special about you
guys who can do this
i personally do not think that this is a
fate or a feature
which can be achieved by being gifted
or being let's say naturally innately
talented
because a one sheer reason that
everyone's born with the same
let's say mathematical uh what do we say
raw material isn't it's it's just about
how you train it and
um my my question again which i which
again i think i'll do
more as we go which is to compare it
compare math
with being the sport is that if one
wants a
ripped body with with with the tight
six-pack is it is it really possible for
everyone
yes but it does take the effort which is
to train to diet to do a bunch of stuff
yeah so it sounds like you're saying
it takes you know the willingness and
the motivation to want to do this
and also a lot of hard work um yeah i
guess
training like any classic olympian for
for any other sport i guess so you know
i'd be curious to know when
when you were training for this um
what was your sort of daily routine how
did you find the time
to to do this kind of study so
uh i mean my journey in mental
calculation started when i was very
young very very young
so um i actually met with an accident
when i was five when i was
bedridden for an entire year that has
nothing to do with my calculation
abilities
but uh at that point of time i picked up
puzzles and
calculations as a way which is the eight
magic squares we did a bunch of other
stuff which we
genuinely let's say cm in in our daily
routine right so i mean
uh this was the point of time where i
sort of picked and started falling in
love with what puzzles and math and
numbers and stuff are
i fumbled on to let's say picking mental
calculation as something which i was
interested in
and started going for regional
championships and i won the regionals
nationals and the international
championships in the span of three years
directly i was the international
champion in
speed calculation under the age of 20
years by the time i was 13
thousand singapore my routine when i did
practice for this was
um i used to go to school come back
around 4 p.m in the evening and then
sort of work on because i mean at the
end of the day
i would consider mental math to be a
sport which i would
which again gives it a value of
entertainment right so i mean for me
it never was that okay sit in front of
the paper
solve this exam it was about give this
attempt try doing this better
uh play better so the it it's
the kind of satisfaction or the sense of
achievement you get when you
get your get your soccer balls swing in
the air
and and that's pretty much what what
drove me forward i used to practice for
around six to seven hours a day
consistently for three to four years
today i don't practice as much
but i still make it a point that i'm
active for at least one one and a half
hour every day to sort of look into this
and
pursue this further because i think this
has answers to
a lot of things which human cognition
has to
scope in and do more in great yeah
one thing i'd be curious to ask is that
you know on
on my channel i've done a few videos in
the past
relating to exams and specifically exams
in india things like the jee to get into
university and
before we were recording you said that
you'd gone on to study maths
at university so clearly you know
at the same time you were studying for
this you know mental maths you were also
studying your
your normal school work right and did
you ever sit the jee
and have to do exams at the same time
how was that
balancing them i i really did well in my
jee in fact i i've actually scored a one
one
five one one one twenty in my day in
math
so uh that was so again right i would i
would
look at it in in two directions which is
uh
mathematical acumen building can happen
from any side
it's about i personally look at this as
a mountain you can climb it from any
forte but the end is mathematical
excellence
and um and there's no way you miss out
on things as you climb
so i mean for instance if i am doing a
speed calculation
and at some point of time i wanted to do
an approximation
there's no way i can do that without
knowing the taylor series
there's no way i can do that without
knowing knowing how do i
extrapolate and and and sort of
do a bunch of other things when i'm
let's say approximating a few
calculations there's a lot of ideologies
which go behind it
be it be it be it let's say coding
sections we'd be a lot of other stuff
which
i think is a part of what we do number
theory majorly so
uh prime factorization if that's the
calculation i'm going for
i learned a lot of formal math through
the problems i faced while i scaled uh
on becoming the world's fastest human
calculator so i would say that
my journey in math was intertwined i
really liked a comment that you made
a bit before about kind of what you had
learned about a human brain and about
learning itself through your experiences
and
i wonder if you could talk maybe a
little bit more about that because maybe
that
it kind of gives a usefulness as well to
to what you're doing not that it
you know needs a usefulness because i
know many sports
you do just for the sake of showing
what's possible but it seems like here
the mental calculation stuff can kind of
reveal a bit more about
how we work how we think noam chomsky a
very famous linguist
says that you sort of look at the world
the way you learn language which is
watching the world through the language
club
glass which is one of the most
revolutionary works between language and
cognition
um i personally think that um
language and um and the way you learn
numbers
sort of determine um how you look at the
world in general and
if i have to put it this way from
several researches which have been done
by
piaget or a lot of other mathematician
philosophers who worked on this or
mathematical
uh psychologist it's observed
more so now than ever that um the way
some a kid or a student learns the
number system
the way they learn the operations of
math
the way they learn how naturally one
flows from the other logical
argumentation and stuff
sort of determines their
cognitive compass if i have to say this
that way when i say cognitive compass
i'm talking about the working memory
the iterative memory the long-term
memory the reflex the ability to
partition thought
the ability to parallel think a lot of
things here which is
um and if i have to compare it with
let's say computers
or let's say how a computer functions
it's about how you develop your ram
how you develop your your gpu how you
develop develop your
processor or however that goes yeah i
guess on that
and and also bringing back the you know
parallels to sports why do you think
that you are able to beat for example
shakuntala's record
and i i asked that because you know in
sports in some sports maybe marathon
running or something else you see that
over time
people seem to be getting faster maybe
it's the shoes or the swimsuits they're
wearing or
maybe it's the way we train but do you
think in a similar way that people
are getting smarter is that why records
are being broken here
sure i could i could probably do that
because i mean i personally
um i think my practice
majorly has not been through pen and
paper
solutions it has been aided by software
a lot
right and i would say that that's
something which um
which i think plays a very key role it's
this way right i mean
there's two ways to approach let's say
running a murder for that same marathon
which is
one is to keep running for that hundred
meters expecting growth
or do 10k runs do runs with weights
do runs with something else train
yourself in ten different things
so that eventually when you come back to
this you're better mental calculation
and the art of it
is slowly in decline which is i mean
when i look forward
when i when i talk to let's say 60 year
old or veteran 70 year old
or veterans across the globe or i mean
whenever i go and talk
they're way quicker at what they do than
let's say people of my age or under
because of
the um the reliance on um
calculators a lot which is great for
instance i mean no one really wants to
calculate
46 and a half we don't really want to do
that because there's some machines doing
it for it
so when i compare it with the sport this
is exactly what i say and i think i'll
probably repeat it here which
establishes the point usain bolt runs
for 100 meters
right the reason he runs for the 100
meters is to
make sure and people inspire people to
say that okay see
this is what being fit is it's not that
he does not have a car
so it's not that he does not have a car
so i would i probably end up with that
saying that
if you're today if you're here you
should probably be using world from
alpha
if you're here you should be using your
matlabs and mathematica if you're not
you're
not in the math game but at the same
time it's extremely important for you to
train your brain
and there's no better exercise than
counting and trust me you know
that's that's literally what i put here
brain exercise
is is i personally think that math if
you lose out on calculations to be a
way in which you trained yourself you're
sort of missing out one
one part of the jigsaw puzzle it's
really interesting to hear that
perhaps technology has played a role in
helping
you to break records i guess i'd love to
hear a little bit more about
you know what you're doing now your
current mission math failure
is one of the major reasons why students
drop out of school
which is uh we just drop out of any
other educational trajectory they can
have
so i think the problem which i
go on and i probably wish to solve this
to sort of at least make
math not the speed breaker for someone's
career opportunity because
it does it it shouldn't be that hard and
and
um if you if you let's say inspire
people into saying that because i think
that the problem is twofold one is
that it's the social perception that
math is boring which i think
it's existent regardless of the country
i'm talking about oh not math not really
not my thing
oh you do math you're a geek so i'm
trying to change that by let's say doing
performances and
stage shows across the globe this can
the competitive side of
um you know human calculation it will
really help some people to get
inspired with math for some people it
won't be quite right because it might
bring that
you know the sense of pressure and
competitiveness that comes along with
exams too it can it can actually
sometimes be detrimental so
i think one approach will not work for
everyone this is clearly work
and yeah i i would like to add a little
disclaimer that you know
i personally studied math at uni as well
and
i found that yeah you can you can get by
just fine without being good at
arithmetic and
it's not really going to hold you back
but it's interesting to hear your story
of of a case where it's actually really
helped propel you forward math phobia is
existent i mean let's accept it
that there is a scare of every math exam
which comes your way
uh the two ways to go about it one is to
as you said i mean i think as uh you've
pointed out also that
um competitively getting it over getting
over with is not
always the best way to go about it also
because of the fact that
um if you really want to write a book
you
don't really have to be a spell b
champion it's as simple as that
uh but both of them have their own
beautiful
forms and i believe that moving to
moving forward
we have more people who sort of work
towards
catering such experiences globally where
kids
no longer are scared of math but are
accepted
they accept it as let's say a part of
their life just as
we do with english or any other native
language we speak
great yeah it's a big mission but i
think it's a good one
yeah one little question i'd like to end
with is
do you have maybe a role model or or
someone that
you really look up to maybe from history
or now
uh actually a lot of mathematicians but
let's let me restrict to a couple of
them uh
one very very major uh inspiration
through my life from the beginning how
much ever i understood
uh him or not from the beginning was
srinivasa ramanujan
yeah and uh i mean i would say that
my devotion towards his work is is i
think
has a it goes a long way because of
uh the fact that the fact that okay one
is obviously the cultural
the the sort of indian-ness and the the
promotion of
what he has done in global globally but
the sheer nature of let's say
every time i look up into let's say read
more i realized that oh oh
this is more apt to what i do so i mean
whenever whenever i was
fumbling across a bunch of things i've
somehow always come to
a certain paper of his which i'm like oh
wow this i think
is applicable to what i do so i would
say that he was one of
my major inspirations around of let's
say performances
and making math a culture
or or let's say something which people
consume in india
i'm thankful for shakuntala devi she was
never a formal mathematics
person herself she was never formally
trained
but i think the relatability of a
mathematician
to an average um
citizen of a country is i think
something which
uh which i think i've learned a lot from
great well yeah
i find both of those people also very
inspirational so
yeah i mean nameless to say the other
couple of people
include uh laplace and newton i mean
i've
not gone there but yeah but i've not
gone there now yeah
some of the greats yeah all right well
congratulations on all of your success
and thanks for sharing your insights
thank you thanks a lot thank you it was
nice nice being here
you